baby focus
i can't
that's bianca bryant making buckets just
like her dad kobe bryant
on sunday bb's mom vanessa bryant shared
that clip alongside some sweet pics of
her daughter spending time with pau
gasol's family
but first back to that video phoebe
focus
i can't
yep bianca focused all right that's the
five-year-old making the shot with pow
his wife and vanessa cheering her on
let's watch the adorable moment one more
time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
vanessa also shared this a cute pic of
bianca her sister capri and pow's
daughter elizabeth sitting on his lap
and here's a shot of the three little
girls holding hands and staring off into
the sunset then there's this pick
featuring vanessa's oldest daughter
natalia getting in on all the fun
vanessa's return to social media comes
after she took a brief break ahead of
the second anniversary of the helicopter
crash that killed kobe their 13 year old
daughter gianna and seven others
the mother of four shared photos of
bouquets of flowers from her good
friends including beyonce khloe
kardashian sierra and russell wilson
david and victoria beckham and more one
thing's for sure vanessa's friends have
been by her side since the tragedy
including lala anthony when e.t spoke
with the tv personality in 2020 she
opened up about vanessa's resilience i
talked to her every single day and just
you know continue to
pray for her and uh
stay positive for her she i tell her
every day she's the strongest woman i
know and
i'm really really proud of just
how she's handling everything and just
want to continue to be there you know as
much as i can for her as a friend she's
just an amazing and amazing human being
just just amazing
now vanessa is dedicated to honoring her
late husband and daughter's legacies as
she continues to celebrate their
accomplishments prior to her latest
posts on january 22nd she shared this
throwback photo with kobe and a
three-year-old natalia from his historic
81-point game the caption of course 81
and two heart emojis